le 7 8 en direct entre 18 et 19h si vous
nous suivez donc en direct du lundi au
jeudi également 19h 22h31 minuit et
n'oubliez pas notre site internet
www.tvil 78.com pour voir toutes nos
vidéos j'accueille à présent
Erika von gastro et Marie-Thérèse
gossland de l'association Valentin avis
bonsoir donc à toutes les deux demain
quatre janvier journée mondiale du
braille et puis également sur ce plateau
Mathieu Lopez bonsoir vous êtes de
l'Association des Paralysés de France
l'antenne des Yvelines qui poursuit sont
un action pour le droit à une vie
affective et sexuelle pour les personnes
en situation de handicap moteur on va
débuter cette prochaine séquence par la
journée mondiale du braille le 4 janvier
depuis 2001 cette journée a pour but de
célébrer la naissance de Louis Braille
souligné ce handicap et puis rappeler
aussi l'existence de cet alphabet
tactile qui porte son nom vous en
attendez quoi concrètement de cette
journée aujourd'hui chacune
dis donc ça fasse un peu plus de
publicité pour le braille parce que
c'est un peu moins pratiqué disons par
les aveugles
est-ce que l'objectif c'est aussi de
mettre la lumière sur l'action que vous
faisez au quotidien l'association
donc à Versailles on donne des cours de
braille comme les personnes qui perdent
la vue c'est l'une des missions c'est
une démission de l'association et le
braille maintenant est un petit peu
décrié mais il y a pas d'autres qui
l'assure une autonomie que l'on ne peut
pas avoir autrement que par la lecture
ce qui est nécessaire
à nos malvoyants vous nous dites le
Braille est un petit peu décrié vous
nous dites le braille doit être mis en
lumière on doit le médiatiser un petit
peu plus expliquer nous Erica von gastro
pourquoi aujourd'hui le braille a
mauvaise presse ou en tout cas pas assez
de presse
disons c'est un peu les nouvelles
technologies
disons en informatique qu'on utilise un
peu plus les synthèses vocales qui sont
plus accessibles et plus facile alors
qu'il existe aussi des plages brayes et
du braille informatique mais qui est un
peu plus difficile d'accès
l'informatique ne remplace pas le
braille le braille c'est différent non
ça ne remplace pas ils sont
complémentaires tous les deux il y a une
vraie différence aussi j'imagine parce
que le braille on est actif voilà alors
que le niveau de l'Internet lorsque
l'ordinateur lit les phrases qui sont
écrites par exemple ça change que vous
là vous êtes plus ancienne situation
passive ça aussi c'est ce qu'on peut
entendre quelquefois parmi les reproches
qui sont faites à ces nouvelles
technologies
il y a peut-être un exemple qu'on peut
donner dans une vous sortez d'une
formation un malvoyée en sorte d'une
pharmacie avec son paquet de médicaments
il y a les médicaments sont traduits en
braille donc la lecture est plus facile
autrement il n'y a pas de moyens
l'informatique ne l'aidera pas à lire
ces médicaments indispensables est-ce
que vous trouvez qu'il est assez utilisé
aujourd'hui est-ce qu'on voit assez
fréquemment vous mentionnez l'exemple
par exemple voilà des pharmacies les
médicaments ont tous ces inscriptions en
braille mais pour le reste dans les
lieux publics par exemple
dans les musées maintenant ils utilisent
de plus en plus il y a des plaquettes
bras et qui expliquent un peu les œuvres
donc c'est intéressant
les oui les digicode ou dans les
ascenseurs
et les livres qui concerne les livres
par exemple les livres
l'association Valentin a une très grande
médiathèque à Paris avec plus de
milliers de titres embrayés j'aimerais
qu'on développe un petit peu ce système
du braille parce que forcément on en
parle c'est forcément très connu mais
comment ça fonctionne
est-ce que vous avez dans les mains un
petit déj voilà
qu'on utilise pour le braille donc c'est
c'est une combinaison de ces six points
et si je tourne là je vais faire une
autre lettre
donc là je vais je vais faire
un F ou on peut on peut faire d'autres
d'autres lettres
parce que vous donnez des cours de morue
alors à qui sont destinés ces cours
comment se passe les cours
si on estimé à toute personne qui est
déséroses d'apprendre le bras qui a
perdu la vue et c'est assez difficile
selon l'âge je pense que c'était ça
aussi le sens de ma question parce que
c'est forcément plus difficile parce
qu'on dit que les langues étrangères
sont plus difficiles quand on est plus
âgés alors est-ce que c'est le cas aussi
pour le braille par exemple pour le moi
j'ai pu constater et que l'élève qui
sont plus âgés en plus de difficultés au
toucher
une sensibilité moins grande donc comme
le braille c'est quand même la lecture
des doigts donc forcément c'est beaucoup
plus difficile qu'est-ce qu'on peut tout
écrire avec le braille tout calculer
mathématique il y a du bruit pour la
musique voilà informatique on utilise
pour tout nous avons réalisé un petit
micro-trottoir je vous propose de
l'écouter savez-vous comment se lit le
braille
je sais pas je sais juste qu'on enfin
ils sont censés toucher et avec un
contact tactile il vérifie ils peuvent
déchiffrer mais c'est j'en sais pas plus
le braille oui on pose le doigt sur le
livre et puis après c'est au toucher en
fait c'est ça ah oui plus ou moins donc
avec des petits points qu'on
touche et en fait ça traduit des lettres
quoi donc voilà le braille et ben oui
c'est ce sont des points qui sont
alignés selon un rectangle
et chaque
formation de lignes et de colonnes
représente une lettre
fonctionnent exactement le braille c'est
la langue pour les sourds je pense et
c'est ce qui leur permet de pouvoir lire
des petits desserts de petits points
c'est une sorte de code justement pour
qu'il puisse avoir accès à la lecture
globalement le brailler tout même connu
malgré quelques petites erreurs dans le
micro-trottoir on a évoqué ses cours
justement qui qui sont donnés
l'association Valentin avis je me tourne
vers vous
Marie-Thérèse Gosselin pardon les cours
sont payants comment ça se passe pour
l'association une petite rétribution est
demandée je crois
Erika c'est 15 euros pour l'année 15
euros
pour que les élèves pensent que c'est
pas c'est sérieux
forcément ils sont motivés présents
c'est pour motiver donc tous ces élèves
ils sont nombreux d'ailleurs
pour l'instant mais s'il y a des
candidats et encore de la place
est passé quels sont les autres les
autres actions qui sont menées par votre
association qu'on fasse un petit point
et qu'on présente l'association Valentin
à vide dont on parle souvent
l'association Valentin oui à son siège à
Paris et il y a un comité pour les
Yvelines qui a son siège à Versailles il
y a 85 comités régionaux en France bon
celui de Versailles que qu'elle nous
adhérons
à de nombreuses activités la première
activité c'est l'accueil et la réception
des maloyans qui viennent se chercher un
peu d'aide et de secours on les on les
dirige on les dirige vers différentes
activités que nous proposons
les activités sont les cours de braille
des cours d'informatique une formation
en informatique il y a des
des loisirs des loisirs des visites des
visites tactiles de de musées
des sorties oui des sports aussi des
sorties
aussi il y a aussi du cinéma en audio
description et que l'on présente nous
faisons aussi des cafés rencontres
deux fois par mois
il y a des gens des après-midi de
lecture qui se font aussi il y a du
sport du la natation du tandem tout ce
qu'on peut imaginer et même plus encore
proposé par cette association Valentin à
lui dont une des antennes est basée à
Versailles il y a quelque chose
d'important qui va se produire au mois
de juin un triathlon
national où il y aura une cinquantaine
d'équipes qui viendront pour faire de la
course à pied de la du tandem et du
canoë kayak sur le canal de travail donc
c'est une grosse
intérêt et il y a des cours de cuisine
il y a aussi beaucoup de travail qui se
fait au niveau de l'accessibilité ça
c'est autre chose en ville et dans les
transports et je suis encore mais la
liste était déjà très complète
la liste est très très longue j'en
reviens juste document effectivement les
journaux municipaux sont quelquefois
proposés justement sur ces sur ces
versions là vous faites bien de de
mentionner j'en reviens juste donc au
bras et à l'occasion de cette journée
mondiale de demain sachez aussi que sur
le site internet de l'association
Valentin lui vous pouvez envoyer des
cartes de vœux virtuelles en braille
voici juste une petite capture d'écran
qui vous permet de devoir que lorsque
vous saisissez votre texte il est
transcrit en braille c'est posté sur
Internet votre destinataire le recevra
sous une forme qui va lui paraître
plutôt codée et il sera redirigé vers le
site internet de l'association et là il
aura la traduction de son message et ça
permettra surtout c'est le but de
l'association de faire connaître son
action et pourquoi pas récupérer des
dons aussi parce que vous fonctionnez
sur les dons et les dons sont importants
pour conclure
les donateurs sont toujours les
bienvenus parce qu'on a grand besoin
toutes ces activités représentent
notamment le matériel il y a aussi le
matériel spécialisé qui est très
important il y a beaucoup de choses
et ce matériel est relativement assez
cher donc les dons sont toujours les
bienvenus rendez-vous sur le site
internet de l'association donc pour
envoyer ces cartes de vœux virtuelles
profitez-en nous avons jusqu'à la fin du
mois de janvier pour nous souhaiter la
nouvelle année merci à toutes les deux
d'être venu sur le plateau journée
mondial du braille ce sera demain
Mathieu Lopez on va s'intéresser
maintenant à l'action de la PF juste
après une petite pause qu'attendez-vous
pour 2013 tout au long du mois nous
sommes allés à votre rencontre avec
cette question et on écoute vos réponses
tout le monde garde son travail on
trouve un bon travail et puis
tout le monde reste en bonne santé
peut-être de réussir mes études ce
serait pas mal comme tout le monde
beaucoup de bonheur santé choses simples
une vie tranquille travail beaucoup de
santé pour tout le monde un peu moins de
pauvreté en France parce que je pense
qu'on peut faire beaucoup plus pour les
plus démunis et puis effectivement que
le monde va tourner un peu plus rond et
qui est moins de moins de guerre voilà
tous les cas bonne année tout le monde